[Musique]
bonjour eugène larcher
bonjour monsieur audio le temps le
président de l'espace sud qui est dans
son caddie ce matin au lendemain des
explications données par votre
communauté d'agglomération sur cet
épineux dossier du 6 mai des comptes
financiers
le compte administratif de l'ancien
syndicat intercommunal du centre et du
sud de la martinique
le 6 mai qui gérait l'eau et
l'assainissement pour seize communes de
l'île
dès hier vous êtes s'opposer gène
larcher à toute idée de l'augmentation
du prix de l'eau vous l'avez dit mais
est ce que ce n'est pas quelque chose
finalement ce ne soit pas un passage
obligé pour pour les contribuables du
sud il faut d abord que je vous dise que
je rappelle la prise de compétence
puisque si nous n'avons rien demandé
c'est parce qu'effectivement qu on vous
l'avait dit il y avait seize communes
dont deux de la cacem qui ont rejoint ou
d'ici à 2014 et deux de cap nau dignité
et aux belles qui ont rejoint captons a
finalement bon il va céder 12 les 12 du
sud
la loi dit quoi le syndicat et le même
périmètre que la communauté à communauté
se substituer aux syndicats
alors il ya eu l'arrêté du préfet en
date
du 31 décembre pour 2015 2000 2016
puisque sa part dit du 1er janvier 2017
que nous avons que nous avons eu cette
compétence vous arrêté du 6 de son
passif législatif du 6 de ses actifs et
des passifs
on aurait préféré qu'il y un actif 1
mais là aujourd'hui c'est un passif
puisque le 6è fortement d'été est
aujourd'hui en situation d'insolvabilité
alors et en 2016 les résultats de
couture était et le fonds de roulement
le fonds de roulement notamment était
très très largement négatif plus le
moins de 23 millions mon domaine 23
millions d'euros
la capacité de désendettement du
syndicat ce qu'on appelle la solvabilité
at elle sur et critique de 15 ans donc
les comptes administratifs sont rejeté
les comptes administratifs sont rejetés
vous avez assimilé ce massif aux préfets
de l'eau a été rejetée pour sincérité
parce qu'il y à des hausses est fictif
il y a notamment le lalala une recette
de 6 millions 3 disons que la cacem plus
que le cycle d'invendus de loi la cacem
1 que la cacem aurait aurait payé mais
jusqu'à aujourd'hui la cacem n'a pas
régularisé sur la casse elle conteste le
prix de l'eau non alors si c'est de
l'argent qui ne rentrera pas ne rentrera
pas d'autant plus que ça c'est 2015 et
le courrier que j'ai reçu du président
de la cacem c'est à peu près 9 millions
qui seraient réclamés bon alors c'est
bien pour vous dire que mais dans la
convention qui a été signée le contrat
qui a été signé entre le 6 et l'asm eux
prévoient quoi prévoit que si la cacem
ne paie pas c'est le sexy pour le relais
qui va payer
mais ce qu'il ya jacent dans le second
qu'il n'y a jamais eu de la même
convention ni entre le 6 et la cacem ni
entre la cacem et l'asm
alors aujourd'hui je ne
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi et non en est on arrivé là
bon la question reste posée alors ne
tourne plus autour du pot le jeu de
marché oui c'est de l'incompétence ou de
la malhonnêteté de la part de l'ancien
président du 6 je ne suis pas là vous
critiquez le l'homme mais l'action
j'avoue que healy a bag drop le fait
qu'aujourd'hui qu'il y ait 21 millions à
payer 21 millions demande à des
entreprises n'ont pas touché et il y à
quelques entreprises qui meurent des
entreprises qui meurent rihanna n
puisqu'elle a disparu il y en a d'autres
qui sont obligés de licencier
qu'est ce que moi j'ai fait parce que là
aujourd'hui je peux pas signer deux
mandats on n'y a pas d'argent alors j'ai
signé des attestations que j'ai donnée
aux entreprises qui sont allés voir le
rebond pour éventuellement débloqué
quelque au fond j'ai eu des appels de la
préfecture du secrétaire général gilbert
eustache d un sursaut et dans ce studio
que l'argent est là vous n'avez qu'à
aller le chercher
elle a t-il des notifications vous aurez
le dieu lui demander est-ce qu'il a reçu
des notifications puisque gilbert et ça
c'est très bien que pour des travaux il
faut d'abord d'un plan de financement
un plan de financement donc c'est de
l'incompétence c'est de l'incompétence a
fait un peu de financement bouclé il
faut aussi qu'il y ait des notifications
des notifications de recettes et à ce
moment quand on a ces notifications on
peut lancer les travaux
sinon si on les lance on trouve le moyen
d'avoir des avenants on trouve le moyen
de relancer le marché dont pauvres
d'autres de la grèce alors que gilbert
et stages il dit que
qu'il y a des recettes on interrogeait
nous avons interrogés et les travaux
démarrés il n'y a aucune recette en
attente
donc il est amateur il sort du numéro 10
h est un menteur il sort aujourd'hui il
sort aujourd'hui un document disant que
la chambre régionale des comptes aurait
demandé à la cacem aux préfets de faire
bloquer 4 millions et quelques qui
serait reversé mais jusqu'à maintenant
on attend mais pas voulu répondre sur la
question de l'incompétence le songe de
leur stage mais toujours est il que je
marchais je ne suis pas là pour
critiquer un homme pour porter un
jugement sur l'homme mais sur l'action
de l'homme vu de l'extérieur est ce que
vous admettez est ce que vous comprenez
est-ce que vous reconnaissez que ça peut
être vu cette histoire du 6 mai comme
une gigantesque vagabondage vieux
dossier qui pèse l'eau en euros dossier
que vous avez choisi de transmettre au
préfet c'est ce c'est la procédure
c'est une passe en retrait pour vous
dédouanez pour ne pas être responsable
de tout ce faire chaud que vous avez
entre les mains
non mais pas du tout parce que la loi
dit quoi à partir du moment qu'on a bu
deux qu'un déficit est supérieur à 5%
voulez-vous vous les collectivités de
plus de 5000 habitants en transmet on
transmet la les côtes qui ont été
rejetés à l'unanimité par les élus de
l'espace une on a transcrit vais au
préfet
on a du mal à reprendre quelque chose
alors allez-y c'est au préfet
aujourd'hui de saisir la chambre
régionale des comptes c'est au préfet de
savoir s'il ya une enquête
complémentaire ou pas et à la chaux
régional d'école de faire des
préconisations mais je dis et je le
répète je voulais être entendu dans la
chambre régionale des comptes parce
qu'il est hors de question il est hors
de question d'augmenter le prix de l'eau
le lot coûte déjà très cher ici
comparativement à la france
métropolitaine et ses 5 euros que sa
cote ici pour 3 ou 5 euros 23 ans et
3,90 en france alors mais c'est vraiment
mais c'est dois m'accrocher aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas demander aux
contribuables martiniquais je ne dis
même par votre immeuble du sud aux
contribuables martiniquais
deux pays davantage pour les dérives de
certes eugène marché eugène larcher
hier vous étiez avec les élus de
l'espace sud
on a du mal à comprendre que les
communes du sud qui ont des élus qui
siègent au 6 on a du mal à comprendre
que ces élus découvrent à cette
situation il y a les élus du cij le du
sud il y a deux élus pas comme une
peluche deux élus du robert des élus
deux élus de tri ni qu'ils ont découvert
à partir du 1er janvier 2017 il forma
tion de sang leur a été dispensée à san
francisco effectivement sorti les
chiffres les chiffres les dossiers il y
a eu le compte de gestion
on a eu on a reçu des chefs
d'entreprises et on a reçu aussi des ddd
d'autres même des élus qui viennent nous
voir ils les élus ont découvert que la
procédure avait laissé espérer croiser
certains chantiers ouverts mais vous
avez bien entendu que c'est à des élus
disent que quand quand ils posaient des
questions
on disait que tout allait bien et puis
il y à il ya le président de l'exécutif
il ay l'appui des décisions couche là
sans consulter peut-être son conseil
syndical sans consulter son bureau sans
consulter ses vice-présidents ses élus
il ya l'idée de vous à nous dire qu'il
est comme à gauche il ya des décisions
qui ont été prises gilles il est là il a
fonctionné seul à entendre les élus les
auditeurs j'ai marché les contribuables
ceux qui sont invités à aller aux urnes
ce week-end pour la présidentielle au
mois de juin prochain pour les
législatives en septembre les
sénatoriales il se pose des questions
forcément lorsqu'il entendait faire
propre celle du cycle se pose des
questions sur l'efficacité sur la
compétence sur l'honnêteté des élus une
affaire comme celle ci risque de laisser
des traces
c'est vrai mais il faut pas stigmatiser
forcément les élus il y en a peut-être
qui commettent des erreurs mais il y en
a aussi qui sont honnêtes et qui
travaillent qui donnent de leur temps
qu'ils donnent de leur temps qu'ils
donnent de leur honnêteté qui donnent de
leur
de l'eure qui sacrifient beaucoup de
choses pour se rendre au sommet dans la
disposition de la communauté d'aidé en
tout cas de l'électorat qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire pour que ça ne se reproduise
pas l'intérêt ici que ce n'était
citoyens il y à il y a
il y à ça mais il faut pas quoi il faut
belge indique qu'il faut pas les
stigmatiser
faut pas croire que tous les élus sur
les malhonnêtes ce n'est pas j'espère
bien sûr n'est pas vrai ce père bien ce
n'est pas vrai mais je préfère regarder
alors il n'y a plus il y a le contrôle
de légalité c'est indiqué yann décision
qui est prise quand il ya une
délibération
quand il y à aussi
une décision prise en conseil au conseil
syndical en la décision passant de
l'égalité forcément il ya le regard de
l'état il y a le regret de l'état quand
il est à malversations corps il y a une
et cohérence quelconque c'est aussi aux
services de l'état de faire appel à un
autre
c'est ça que votre favorite rigoler rose
de prendre ses responsabilités dans ce
dossier aujourd'hui ce que je dis c'est
vrai qu'il faut payer les entreprises à
l'espace sud nous allons faire des
efforts puisque il y a pas d'argent
puisque nous sommes une ligne de
trésorerie de 7 millions ou venir en
aide aux entreprises mais nous n'allons
pas comblé seul ce déficit il faut que
l'état aussi papa parle bien d'une aide
exceptionnelle puisse puisse donner
aider à combler ce déficit criard et les
jeunes l'argent dentition caisse des
mises en place 19% pour 15 nord nous
surtout quand il aurait 80 go pour nous
alors là nous nous sommes plaints faire
des efforts mais il faut pas qu'on
choisit sur la fed merci d'avoir été
avec nos jeunes larcher président de
l'espace sud merci d'être venu avec nous
votre journée
[Musique]